j'ai trouvé un moyen de résoudre le
problème de l'énergie avec du béton oui
tu béton pas pour construire des
barrages ou planter des éoliennes mais
du béton pour alimenter le réseau
éclairé chauffer je vais vous expliquer
saviez vous que l'énergie la moins chère
aujourd'hui et l'énergie solaire grâce à
la baisse spectaculaire du prix des
panneaux solaires
si maintenant vous mettez un panneau
solaire dans un endroit très bien
éclairé vous obtenez un kilowattheure à
2 centimes
c'est deux fois moins que les énergies
classiques et polluantes
en plus d'être la moins chère l'énergie
solaire est extrêmement abondante le
carré rouge dans le sahara qui fait à
peu près un quart de la france
représente la surface de panneaux
solaires permettant d'alimenter la
planète entière en électricité alors si
l'énergie solaire et si peu cher et si
abondante pourquoi n'est-elle pas notre
source d'énergie principale parce qu'il
ya un problème
l'intermittence le jour il ya du soleil
mais la nuit il n'y en a pas
cette courbe en cloche vous montrent que
l'énergie solaire arrive de manière
concentrée au milieu de la journée
mais notre consommation elle est plutôt
constante
on peut la représenté par cette ligne
blanche si on veut alimenter notre
réseau électrique avec énormément
d'énergie solaire il est absolument
nécessaire de stocker le surplus
d'énergie en milieu de journée en jaune
pour pouvoir l'utiliser le soir et la
nuit
stocker n'est pas un problème
technologique
c'est un problème économique on se
stocker l'électricité avec des batteries
mais on ne sait pas stocker
l'électricité de façon rentable
avec des batteries les batteries comme
celle de au lithium de votre téléphone
fonctionne selon une réaction chimique à
chaque cycle de charge décharge elles
s'usent elle perd de sa capacité
il faut les changer au bout de quelques
années et quand on fait le calcul du
coût de stockage dans les batteries
on trouve qu'il est très élevée on
estime à 10 centimes d'euros par
kilowattheure
si bien que l'énergie solaire une fois
stockée dans les batteries n'est plus du
tout intéressante elle n'est pas
rentable elle a besoin de subventions
elle ne peut pas se développer
alors moi je ne suis pas chimiste je
suis ingénieur en mécanique
il ya quelques années je travaille chez
total sur les moteurs je vais au salon
de détroit et je vois une start up qui
propose de remplacer les batteries des
voitures électriques par des volants pas
des volants pour conduire dans des
volants c'est un cylindre ou un disque
qui tourne à très grande vitesse pour
stocker l'énergie sous une forme qu'on
appelle énergie cinétique
alors les volants été fait jusqu'ici on
a scié depuis quelques années on fait
même des volants en carbone le très gros
avantage des volants par rapport aux
batteries c'est qu'ils ont une durée de
vie illimitée
malheureusement pour les voitures
électriques les volants se sont avérés
trop lourd mais moi j'ai eu la
conviction que quand le poids n'est pas
important les volants avait un très gros
potentiel pour stocker de l'énergie des
énergies renouvelables et j'ai créé ma
société
alors avec mon équipe de quatre
personnes nous avons fait des volants en
acier plus en fonte
nous étions à la recherche dans la quête
du graal que tout le monde en ce moment
cher c'est le stockage à faible coût
mais ces matériaux classiques sont trop
chers il fallait trouver quelque chose
de complètement différent
l'an dernier j'ai eu une intuition il
fallait tester le béton et j'ai
découvert que le béton est un matériau
extraordinaire pour stocker l'énergie
en effet le béton permet de stocker pour
dix fois moins cher que les matériaux
classiques et je peux vous dire dans une
vie d'ingénieurs ça n'arrive pas souvent
de faire un aussi grand progrès en aussi
peu de temps
alors bien sûr vous allez me dire bah si
c'est si facile pourquoi est-ce que
personne n'y a pensé plus tôt
parce que le béton est incompatible avec
les volants le béton ne résiste pas à la
traction si vous tirez dessus il se
casse or un volant quand il tournait
sous mais une force centrifuge très
importante qui le met dans un état de
traction intense si vous faites un
cylindre en béton il éclate dès que vous
le faites tourner ma solution consiste à
comprimer le béton avec un enroulement
sous tension tout autour de telle
manière que le béton reste aux
compressions jusqu'à la vitesse maximale
pour simplifier on va dire que nous le
fils long comme un rôti
ce volant de stockage solaire nous
l'avons appelé veulent alors comment est
ce que ça fonctionne quand il y a de
l'énergie solaire en excès et qu'il faut
la stocker nous utilisons un moteur
électrique pour faire tourner le volant
de plus en plus vite et accumuler de
l'énergie cinétique à la vitesse
maximale on atteint des vitesses comme
celle d'un avion de ligne
un peu moins de 1000 kilomètres heure va
très vite mais il n'y a pas de
frottement car nous avons enlevé l'air
nous avons vidé l'air autour du volant
ce qui nous permet de conserver
l'énergie pendant plusieurs heures pour
récupérer l'énergie on inverse le
système c'est à dire que c'est le volant
qui entraîne le moteur qui à ce
moment-là produit de l'électricité comme
un alternateur alors voilà avec de
l'intuition beaucoup de réflexion et du
béton nous avons trouvé un moyen de
stocker l'énergie à très faible coût
environ 2 centimes d'euros par
kilowattheure
l'association d'un volant en béton avec
des panneaux solaires photovoltaïques
conduit un kilowattheure une énergie
renouvelables disponibles nuit tu es
jour un coût inférieur à celui des
énergies polluantes
alors actuellement cette technologie est
en cours de développement
notre projet à court terme et d'équiper
des petits territoires des petits
réseaux électriques comme la corse la
guadeloupe la réunion des villages
africains qui sont alimentées
essentiellement par des groupes
électrogènes de manière à remplacer le
carburant de ces groupes par de
l'énergie solaire mais notre grand
projet à l'échéance de quatre ou cinq
ans c'est de créer de grandes centrales
photovoltaïques dans des endroits très
ensoleillé comme les déserts de manière
à alimenter le réseau mondial avec une
énergie propre et bon marché et donc une
énergie solaire rentable sans subvention
inutile de vous dire qu'après toutes ces
années de recherche
je suis impatient de voir notre
technologie arrivée sur le marché de
l'énergie et le révolutionner
car avec un coût de stockage aussi
faible les énergies renouvelables vont
enfin pouvoir remplacer les énergies
polluantes
merci